se nos pide dividir 99.0 61 entre 100 y
hay varias maneras de hacer esto pero en
este vídeo lo que quiero hacer es
enfocarme en la manera que yo considero
más rápida entonces pensemos un poco en
esto y también que tenga más sentido
para ti
así que ok 99 tenemos 99.0 61 si lo
fuéramos a dividir entre 10 que pasaría
que que obtendríamos y lo dividimos
entre 10 esencialmente lo que haríamos
es mover el decimal un espacio hacia la
izquierda y si observas esto tiene
sentido porque tendríamos aquí tenemos
algún poco mayor que 99 y si dividimos
99 entre 10 obtenemos algo un poco mayor
que 9 así que vamos muy bien entonces
cuando dividimos esto entre 10 tenemos
el resultado es igual a 9.90 61 así que
qué va a pasar cuando queramos cuando si
queremos dividirlo entre 100 ok 99.0 61
entre 100
que me dará porque cuando yo dividí
entre 10 solo me moví un espacio hacia
la izquierda pero entonces cómo estoy
dividiendo entre 100 me voy a mover dos
espacios a la izquierda así que ahora el
punto decimal se sitúa enfrente del
primer 9 entonces ahí estará el punto
decimal y tiene todo el sentido porque
99 es casi 100 así que 99 dividido entre
100 nos dará algo un poco menor que 1 y
99 punto entonces lo escribo ok 99
puntos 0 61 dividido entre 100 esto es
igual a punto 99 061 y aquí pongo un
cero para que quede un poco más claro
ahora cuando estás cuando mueves el
decimal hacia la izquierda estas
dividiendo entre 10 mientras que si lo
mueves a la derecha estás multiplicando
por 10 y tal vez en alguna ocasión
alguna persona te diga oh espero yo sea
un truco y pon atención porque ese truco
es bastante genial puedes contar el
número de ceros aquí por ejemplo estás
dividiendo entre 100 y 100 tiene dos
ceros
así que como estamos dividiendo movemos
el punto decimal dos espacios hacia la
izquierda y eso eso está muy bien es una
manera muy muy rápida de hacerlo si
tuvieras 2002 por ejemplo entonces lo
más práctico sería contar los dos ceros
que serían 20 y mover moverte 20
espacios a la izquierda y pero pero
porque funciona este método ese es el
verdadero misterio porque aquí estamos
tomando un número que es casi 100 y lo
estamos dividiendo entre 100 entonces
vemos que nos da casi 1 así que tiene
sentido lo ves pero pero también es una
buena manera de de de ver si vas en la
dirección correcta al resultado correcto
si en no sé de aquí algunos años vas a
tener que aprenderte el método
recordarlo ok estoy dividiendo voy a
moverme a la izquierda oa la derecha
entonces recordarás que si estás
dividiendo te vas a mover a la izquierda
y vas a obtener un número más pequeño
mientras que si estás multiplicando te
vas a mover a la derecha obteniendo un
número más